what i want to do in this video is get a
little bit of experience a little to see
a few examples of trying to roughly
estimate the square root of non-perfect
squares so let's say that i had if i
wanted to estimate the square root of 32
and in particular i'm just i'm just
curious between what two integers will
this square root lie
well one way to think about it is 32 is
in between what perfect squares we see
is actually let me make sure i have some
space for future examples so 32 what's
the perfect square below 32 so the
greatest perfect square below 32 is 25
32 is greater than 25 that's 5 squared
so maybe i should write it this way so 5
squared is less than 32
and then 32 what's the next perfect
square after 32
well 32 is less than 36 which is less
than so we could say 32 is less than 6
squared so if you were to take the
square root of all of these sides right
over here we could say that instead of
here we have all of the values squared
but instead if we took the square root
we could say 5
is going to be less than the square root
of 32 which is less than which is less
than 6. notice to go from here to here
to go from here to here and here to here
all we did is we squared things we
raised everything to the second power
but the inequality should still hold so
the square root of 32 should be between
5 and 6. it's going to be 5 point
something let's do another example
let's say we wanted to estimate
we want to say what between what two
integers is the square root of
well we can do the same idea let's
square it
so if we square the square root of 55
we're just going to get to 55
we're just going to get let me do that
same color
55 and say okay 55 is between which two
perfect squares
so the perfect square that is below 55
or i guess the greatest perfect square
that is less than 55 let's see 6 squared
is 36 then 7 squared is 49 8 squared is
64. so it would be 40
it would be 49. i could write that as 7
squared
let me write that that is the same thing
as 7 squared and what's the next perfect
square above it well we just figured it
out 7 squared is 49 8 squared is larger
than 55 it's 64.
so this is going to be less than 64
which is 8 squared
and of course 55 just to make make it
clear what's going on 55 is the square
root of 55
squared that's kind of by definition
it's going to be the square root of 55
squared and so the square root of 55 is
going to be between what it's going to
be between 7 and 8.
so 7 is less than the square root of 55
which is
less than 8. so once again this is just
an interesting way to think about what
would you ask if someone said the square
to 55 and at first you're like oh i
don't know what that is i don't have a
calculator etcetera etcetera if you're
like oh wait wait that's going to be
between 49 and 64. so it's going to be 7
point something it's going to be 7 point
something and you could even get a rough
estimate of 7.1 based on how far away it
is from 49 and 64. you can begin to
approximate things
let's do one more example let's say we
wanted to figure out where does the
square root of
123 lie and once again like always
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think about it yourself between what
two integers does this lie
well if we were to square it you get to
123 and what's the perfect square that
is less that is the greatest perfect
square less than 123. let's see 10
squared is a hundred
11 squared is 121. 12 squared is 144. so
11 squared
so 123 so we could write 121 is less
than 123
which is less than
144 that's 12 squared so if we take the
square roots we could write
that 11 is less than the square root of
which is less than 144. so once again
what's the square root of 123 it's going
to be 11 point something and in fact
it's going to be closer to 11 than it's
going to be to 12. 123 is a lot closer
to 121 than it is to 144. so it might be
i don't know 11.1 something like that so
i don't know if that's exactly right we
would have to check that on the
calculator but hopefully this gives you
whoops i
it's going to be it actually will be
less than 144. but if we want to think
about what consecutive integers does
that be between there's going to be a 12
right over there almost almost made him
well anyway you get the idea hopefully
you enjoyed that